of the workshop
and I will take this time to actually
thank all my co-organizers
so Sebastian such a Paul Jason and
Julian thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so okay sorry I wanna just quickly
introduce you and now we have a talk by
Omri Weinstein he's at the Hebrew
University and at the Columbia
University and he will talk about very
recent work on accelerating the mwu
framework for packing LPS
thanks Monica and to all the organizers
and thanks for everyone for sticking out
uh for the last talk uh so as Monica
said I'll talk about a very recent in
fact ongoing work with uh Cedric and
sorachai who's sitting here
um which develops kind of a new approach
or more precisely a new primitive for
speeding up various long-standing
Network design problems which are
currently stuck on cubic or more
precisely MN time
and feel free to interrupt I'm Israeli
so there's no no need to be
for any politeness okay so
um
oh
Okay so
so as we know many Network design
problems can be formulated as fractional
packing linear programs albeit of
exponential size so some
notable examples are
multi-commodity flows matching problems
stunner cut problems subgraph
connectivity linear Arrangements
essentially any problem which asks to
find the subgraph with satisfying
certain uh property and indeed uh if you
try to write write down the explicit
linear size linear program for these
problems using the uh the graphical
plush and then
um
they will not be positive linear
programs which will be a crucial
property that we'll use in combinatorial
kind of augmenting style path algorithms
so you really need the implicit LP
formulation to get a positive LP
and the running example for the talk
will be the K commodity flow problem
where so what do we have here we get a
directed capacitated graph and a set of
K demand pairs right so the blue pairs
the red pairs the green pairs the yellow
Pairs and you should think of K as huge
right it's potentially N squared kind of
paths right so this is the setting in
this talk so they're in the realistic
cases you know kids is very large and
our goal is to Route the maximum amount
of flow between all the legal demand
pairs while respecting The Edge
capacities
that make sense
okay so if you think about it the
natural packing LP for this problem has
a variable for every path for every
potential path between a legal dementor
right every legal red path every legal
blue path and so forth
right so we have obviously an
exponential constraint Matrix uh
exponential number of variables and each
variable denotes kind of the amount of
flow routing through a specific path
through any one of the potential path
that's going to be important make sense
yeah
and our goal is to Route the maximum
amount of flow respecting these Edge
capacities thanks thanks a lot
um the Dual okay so the Dual of this uh
the Dual program is essentially a
minimum fractional cut problem where the
goal is to assign non-negative Edge
weights
so that
every path the length of every path with
respect to this
link function or weight function is at
least one right so if you think of w as
the integral
uh solution it's just an indicator of a
cut right so all we're asking here is to
find basically if W is just the
indicator of a cut and then this
constraint means it's a natural
certificate of a bottleneck in the graph
right it means that routing one unit of
flow between
any demand pair any legal demand pair it
consumes one unit of volume in the graph
questions about this
this is quite standard right the Primal
and dual programs and notice that
the Primal here so the con you know the
Primal here is a very fat Matrix right
it has an exponential size Matrix we
have exponentially many variables
because we have exponentially many paths
but the Dual has only
um M variables right because the weight
function is just assigning a
non-negative way to the edges that
that's going to be crucial for the
algorithm
okay and as cyan and uh grandma's
already showed us uh this week earlier
this week
what's kind of interesting is that
despite this LP having exponential size
right and gargan konigman uh with an
improvement by Fletcher showed that it's
nevertheless possible to design low
accuracy with independent algorithms for
this problem which are quite efficient
based on a primal dual version of the
multiplicative weight updates method
um and okay so this is what what uh
we're gonna show in a second I just want
to say that it's quite subtle because
for high accuracy
okay commodity flow even for two
Commodities we cannot hope to beat
matrix multiplication time okay because
the problem is equivalent to General LPS
okay so it's really subtle so it's kind
of uh
it's intriguing that for for low
accuracy algorithms positivity of the lp
or packing version of the lp buys us a
lot but in the high accuracy regime we
don't know how to exploit this
okay so this is just a comment another
comment is that if K is small so if we
have only you know 10 commodities
then uh there's a very clever approach
by Sherman to get faster runtimes using
some proximal gradient descent method
with a very clever uh mirror procs
optimization method any questions till
now
all right so to describe the guard
economy algorithm Let Me Assume
throughout the talk that we have unit
capacities it's really not going to
complicate uh uh things so everything's
gonna extend yeah
the running time does not depend on K
Okay so
we always pay all the algorithms I'll
mention pay uh an extra output size
time which is KN and if you think about
it this is tight because you can easily
generate an example of St even just one
commodity where you have K parallel
paths and you'll have to pay again time
just to write down the answer okay so
this is for so this is
like necessary
M times K is you know you can possibly
hope to do a slightly better okay
uh
so the question was am I returning a
fractional floor in integral flow it's
going to be a fractional flow
it's going to be basically
um it's an amount of flow routed on each
but the output is still limited by km
yes uh
is that right
yeah I believe so right yeah okay so we
have forever for all K demand pairs I'm
gonna just uh
uh I'm just going to describe
uh the flow routed on the on One path no
but it's I mean so there's an instance
yeah okay okay okay so so the claim is
that there is an instance where there's
a unique path between every DeMent there
and they're you know just describing the
flow routing on this particular path you
know their k-parel K Edge this joint pad
so you'll have to pay KN this is just
the justification that there are
instances where you the output size is K
times M that's it right okay but yeah
it's a lower bound not enough yeah it's
a lower bound yeah exactly exactly
okay
all right so we're going to assume unit
capacities and it's really everything is
going to go through for General
capacities I'll try to point this out
so the garconimin algorithm is going to
maintain a set of Weights okay so a a
candidate dual solution
okay
and it's going to update those those
this weight function
and it's going to make uh in every
iteration it's going to make a Oracle
call to the following key subroutine
which we call the Monroe uh Oracle and
basically saw this in Grandma's talk
yesterday
which asked to return given the
exponential path Matrix it requires to
return and the current weight Vector it
requires to return the row of the Matrix
that minimizes the inner product with
this
vectors does that make sense so if the
path Matrix in in the case of
multi-commodity flow P denotes
every row here is a path and W is a
non-negative weight function what is the
Min row Oracle computing
just the shortest path right
does that make sense but rows here could
be for General Network design problems
they could be Cuts matchings subgraphs
anything you want okay so it's very
the Monroe Oracle is a very general uh
primitive
okay so here's the full and it kind of
yeah so we kind of measured the
the intuitive for why the intuition for
why you need this Oracle call is it's
going to measure the quality of the
candidate dual solution and here's the
full algorithm Okay so
so what does the algorithm do given the
K Commodities K demand pairs
we start with an empty flow
and with a weight function which is
uniformly one on each Edge
okay so we assign a weight of one to
each Edge and we'll maintain this
increasing monotone increasing function
it's going to be important and we do the
following so as long as they're not a
super congested Edge is not as long as
we have an edge which is not super
congested okay where congestion is just
the amount of flow routing through the
edge in the capacitated cases just
normalized by capacity
that's clear so the congestion is just
the amount of flow routing through an
edge as long as we there is some uh you
know uh as long as there's no super
congested Edge we just call the Monroe
Oracle we compute a shortest path with
respect to the current weight function
okay so we compute a weighted shortest
path with respect to current weight
and we route one unit of flow
along this shortest path
yes
okay so we just compute the shortest
path we augment one unit of flow on this
path this finishes the Primal update and
then for every Edge on this path okay
but so
we find the shortest path p in the T
iteration
uh and for every Edge in this path
we're going to bump up the weight of
this Edge by e to the Epson or one plus
Epsilon it's going to be I'm going to
use the two interchangeably
does that make sense so you're bumping
up the weights only on edges in the
shortest bet okay which intuitively
models the fact that we want to route we
want to augment flow through relatively
uncongested pets that make sense
okay that's it so this is the algorithm
you just repeat that so every time you
compute a shortest path you route one
unit of flow and you bump up the weights
along these bets that's it
how do you so when you return the final
flow do you need to like yeah yeah I'm
going to talk about it but that's the
algorithm okay so okay so I'm actually
going to return the final flow
scaled by something so I'm getting to
this okay
so then should it be well there is a
congested Edge do something or I don't
know so as long as you haven't reached
the threshold congestion ah you you
still keep going more questions
Okay so
just one implication one important
property of this multiplicative update
rule is that observe that weights are
always exponential in the congestion
right because every time we increase the
weight of an edge what does it mean it
means that it was augmented by one unit
of flow right so this will mean that
we also contribute at least one to the
congestion
okay
so here's a six line and that's
completely self-contained analysis
uh for this algorithm based on a
beautiful note that sorachai wrote a
couple years back and I really recommend
the reading it
um
Okay so
it's actually going to be four lines
with a cheat sheet so
um okay so the first observation is that
as Daniel said the remember that the
algorithm never the garconium never
maintains explicit feasibility right we
never enforce feasibility and indeed the
final flow May violate some capacity
right so we'll have to scale down the
the return flow by the maximum
congestion in order
to maintain the to respect the edge
capacities right that that's that's
always going to be feasible
and the claim is that the maximum
congestion is not too bad so you know
it's log M over Epsilon Square so we
won't have to scale down the solution by
too much it will only lose like a login
Factor
why is that well the maximum congestion
is at least that why because this was
our termination condition right by
definition this we stopped when we
congested an edge but the claim is that
it's not much more than that because the
last iteration cannot overshoot this by
much right it's only routing one unit of
flow okay so this is an easy an easy
fact
yes does everyone agree that the maximum
congestion this was our termination
condition the last iteration we cannot
overshoot this by much
okay so the main claim is that the
scaled down flow which is feasible is
not only feasible but it's also one
minor steps on optimal okay and here's a
four-line proof uh uh with the with the
cheat sheet Okay so
it's based on kind of the standard
multiplicative weight analysis so let's
define potential function VT
which measures which just sums up the
current the sum of the current weights
so this is kind of the quality
of the Dual solution maintained by the
um by the by the algorithm right so
notice that once again this may not be a
feasible dual solution because
to be feasible those weights need to
respect the shortest path that every
path has large length greater than one
right that was the Dual constraint right
but if we take this potential the sum of
weight and we scale it down by the
shortest path by the weight of the
shortest path then by definition we're
respecting the Dual constraints right
okay this is pretty important because so
this is exactly why we route through
shortest path through the Monroe Oracle
at each row because we want this is the
cheapest way to scale down the Dual to
be feasible right
is that clear that's that's quite quite
important
what what's feasible the uh what we're
saying is that this this uh this the sum
of weight here which is the Dual
objective because we're in the unit
capacity case
[Music]
it's a candidate solution but it's not
necessarily feasible but the scale down
set of Weights is feasible
scaled by DT no scaled by the weight of
the shortest path okay so DT is a
feasible dual solution does everyone
agree because we just took DT is a
number isn't it it's the value of it yes
the value of the it's the value sorry
sorry say sorry yeah
yeah okay everyone agrees uh that's
exactly why we route through show the
stats okay
all right and now the the claim I'll use
is that because weights evolve
multiplicatively right the update rule
to the weights is multiplicative well
this implies that also the potential
evolves multiplicatively okay and this
is where I'm gonna
use the cheat sheet so
you can increase the number of lines of
the proof by one maybe so
so if you don't see this so if you don't
see this proof what is v t plus one it's
just by definition
it's
the sum of all the weights in the teeth
round
foreign
of all the edges
okay so the edges that do not belong to
the shortest path remain the same right
and the edges that do belong to the
shortest path
get bumped up by I mean e to the Epsilon
times WT but e to the Epsilon is
essentially
one plus Epsilon right
so now I can take this one and throw
them back here
so I get the original weight function w
t of E
this is nothing else but VT
right plus I have the Epsilon
times
all the edges in the shortest path
their weight right
so now
can everyone see this okay so
so now let me just take VT out of the
um there's a common denominator and I'll
have this Plus
right
uh
Epsilon times
this sum okay all the edges in the
shortest path times w e
okay but what is this thing what is the
sum of Weights divided by Phi t
this is exactly DT right this is exactly
the quality of the Dual solution
so does everyone agree so this is
exactly feet
one uh you know
15 times e to the Epsilon over DT right
and again I'm I'm using
I'm using the the fact that OnePlus
Epsilon is roughly e to the Epsilon
okay everyone agrees so this is the only
so if you believe this fact we're
essentially done why because so if you
iterate this potential
uh you know iteratively until the final
iteration using the fact that initial
potential was M right why because the
sum of Weights was one so this is the
initial potential and then you just
iterate this potential you have the
potential is upper bounded by e to the
sum of e over DT so far so good
okay and then you can take out always
the minimum dual solution you've ever
encountered through iterations right
just take it out of the sum and take the
Epsilon out of the sum
and now what is this what is what are we
doing we're summing one unit of flow for
each iteration so what is this thing
this is exactly the quality of the
unnormalized flow right because this
right every every iteration will augment
one unit of flow so this is the quality
of the Primal solution right
yes this is just the quality of the
unscaled unnormalized
exclusion does everyone agree to to this
that's it so we have an upper bound of
the potential on the other hand I claim
that the potential is always at least
the maximum Edge Edge weight that's
clear right the potential the sum of
weight so it's at least the maximum
right and the maximum weight remember we
argue it's also the weights are always
exponential in the congestion we already
said this several times so it's just
exponential in e to the max congestion
this and that's it so now we have an
upper bound now lower bound on the
the potential so if you combine the two
and take logs what do you get you get
that
drop of this which is e times the max
congestion is at most
log m
Plus
this thing
three times
the Primal divided by the Dual yes
okay so let's divide by the left hand
side
okay so I just divide my left hand side
I get one because I okay what happens to
this term when I divide by Epsilon times
the max congestion
the Epsilon disappears and I get the
scale down now it's a prior it's a
feasible Primal solution divided by the
Dual
plus log M over
Max congestion
sorry it should be Epsilon sorry
it should be Epsilon Max congestion
right
that's it this thing is one right and
this thing what was the max congestion
remember
it was log M over Epsilon squared and
this is exactly so what do what happens
here when you divide by log M over
Epsilon Square you get exactly Epsilon
and that's it that's the proof why
because what have we shown here I claim
that this is equivalent or at least it
implies this why this just says that the
Duality Gap
is very close to one is one minus
Epsilon if you want to formal proof just
take Daemon
here times here this is always an upper
bound on an Ops right any dual solution
is an upper bound enough
that's it no nothing hidden under the
rug this is a a really
I really like this uh this proof okay so
this is the yeah is this equivalent to
the proof using the expert so is that
yeah it's it's big okay
it is except there are some
specific details here but it's basically
uh trying to repeat the experts proof so
the multiplicative the vanilla experts
analysis uses exactly this potential
yes we basically charge each of the
violation kind of to the only thing here
is using the mean
no the feasibility issue which doesn't
really occur in the vanilla
multiplication difference
okay whatever so this was correctness
what about if the iteration comes very
simple right so the number of iterations
I claim it's at most the congestion
because every iteration we congest by
one at least one Edge right every
iteration routes one unit of flow
through at least one Edge so what will
happen after M log M over Epsilon
squared iteration the total congestion
on all the edges is this so there must
be a edge which is saturated which has
congestion at least logging over Epsilon
square and this was our termination
condition
okay
good so now the question what is the
overall cost of the Guard condiment
algorithm
and unfortunately implementing the
Monroe Oracle or the shortest path it's
it seems very expensive right naively
you would need to so what would you do
you'd maybe maintain a single Source
shortest path tree
right using dijkstra from every demand
or from every vertex right because you
have to cycle through the demands to
find
the the minimum distance and only then
will you query for to report the path
right I mean I at least I don't really
see a way to to avoid this
all right and so Fleischer got this down
from M times n basically to O of Emperor
amortized per duration using two very
clever observations the first one is
actually very very simple her first
observation was that nothing changes in
the analysis if we replace if we report
Epsilon approximate toward this path
instead of exaggerated spat why is that
because where did we use the shortest
path all we used is that when we scale
by shortest pad it's feasible so now
it's going to be Epsilon feasible that
was that even earlier yeah yeah that's
that's simple the more clever
observation which I won't be able to to
uh to prove but will also use it in our
framework is that flasher observed that
you can group okay you can repeat the
same guard Kahneman algorithm except you
can group the multiplicative weight
iterations into epochs where in each
epoch
each Epoch is associated with a set of
Weights let's say weights between you
know 100 and 110 okay and the gore the
goal is to clear the demands in this
Epoch what does it mean you just need to
repeatedly report shortest paths with
paths inside of length inside this range
okay so if a length of the pad is
outside this range it doesn't
participate in the epoch so you just
need to carve out just to you know pick
out keep picking out shortest paths in
with length in this range and repeatedly
update and bump up the weights on them
and this is I claim that this is
equivalent it's not it's it's equivalent
to the correct in terms of correctness
to the garconingman what does this buy
you okay so what what so first of all is
this clear uh what I'm saying all I'm
doing is instead of reporting shortest
path repeatedly I'm just saying I'm
dividing the iteration into Epoch
defined by ranges of weights and your
goal in a certain EPUB
is to clear is to just report all the
shortest path and update them as long as
their weight is in inside this range
okay I think correctness doesn't change
and what she proved is that the number
of epochs is bounded by logomorph
Epsilon squared now what does it buy her
what what what what does this epoch
so I won't I won't get into details but
basically what it buys you is the
following
it allows you to amortize
the cycling through demand so the claim
is that look at the shortest path tree
if this demand
um if the shortest path if the distance
between demand this demand and any other
demand is outside this range I claim it
will never get into this rate you you
can skip it forever during this Epoch
right why because weights always
increase so if it's not in the range it
will never be in the ring
okay so the intuition is that yeah
you'll maintain those die extra shortest
path but you'll only cycle through
demands once per demand pair in each
epoch okay so the total runtime of
maintaining those shortest path using
dijkstra is going to be M times n
instead of the total time yeah and this
was so the amortized time will be o of M
okay I know this was fast I'm sorry but
this is not the main thing so
okay so basically the Epub based view
allows you to amortize the cost of
cycling through finding the closest pair
right because you have to find the
closest pair this is already a problem
that seems to to be very expensive
flasher shows that monotonicity plus the
Epub based view allows you to cycle only
once per episode three through each Okay
so
pleasure just addressed flow perhaps but
I think
you're suggesting Maybe
are you suggesting that the epoch
analysis applies to a broader set of
packing problems that that's also true
yeah and we'll in fact we'll use this
okay but the point is that getting o of
M
amortized cost per Min row per shortest
path Oracle call
you know it was this was the way to get
it okay because otherwise I don't see
how to I don't see how to get it without
without
okay so this if you believe and digest
what I've said this recovers right so
you have
the garconic the the runtime I claimed
right em iterations or mlogm iterations
of multiplicative weight times o of M
amortized cost per duration right so
this is M squared
okay so the next development in 2010 was
due to madri who showed that the cost
per duration can be improved from
implementing the Monroe the shortest
path Oracle can be further improved for
o of M to of n which sounds really you
know uh uh incredible and indeed what
Fleischer didn't use is basically she
she well she amortized the the cycling
through demands but she never used the
the decremental nature of the problem
the fact that weights she basically
solved from scratch he just ran dijkstra
from scratch using those shortest path
trees and indeed that was main Madrid's
main observation that the problem that
the Min row is solving in the context of
the multiplicative weight algorithm is a
decremental shortest path problem
in fact it's incremental right because
weights increased but you can easily
reduce it to decremental
okay and the upshot is that the criminal
shortest path is a very well studied
problem as Aaron showed us
um
uh using okay so if you have if you want
to solve the decremental single Source
problem on low diameter ball
we have a classic es you know data
structure the esps which solve it uh uh
very fast right so and indeed
I mean this application was a main
driver for the explosion and works in
recent years by touch upon Aaron and all
these uh folks here uh for studying
decremental shortest path problems okay
but the claim is that again this is es
trees are not enough here because again
you what will you do you can maintain an
ES3 for every demand pair decrementally
that's way too expensive right because
you cannot afford to do that so what is
madri's main idea again I'm going to
devote one minute to it basically Madre
says look uh
um let me guess the length of the
shortest path let's call it l
and let me sample
so what madri does basically he samples
a set of L leaders random leaders in the
graph in his observation is that if the
specific shortest path between that you
know that you want to report
this shortest path hits if this is a
hitting set for this shortest path as
long as the shortest path hits this
randomly random set of leaders this is
similar to the third Civic argument then
then we're good then if we maintain a
shortest path tree an ES3 not from all
the vertices but only from the leaders
we'll report this path right because all
we need is a hitting set for this for
the shortest path we don't need to
report an arbitrary Source but there's
this one shortest path as long as we hit
it we're good okay and then he does
exponential guessing on L and okay but
does that make sense roughly
so that is all this on undirected graphs
yeah uh
Madre is on undirected the the the the
right the the framework
for directed as well
uh
uh but then okay I guess that yes the
monotonicity is still yeah okay
yeah I think it's directed as well
actually that's I guess
it is
the data structures can change right the
distance
as well so multiplicative weight updates
like interior Point method they don't
just their belief is to direct their but
you're asking about the specific speed
up for the Monroe problem for the yeah
for the sort of stuff
okay so it's it's it also handles the
record I didn't remember them
okay and this is the state of the art on
the problem right omn is currently over
Epsilon squared this is the state of the
art and madri argues it's you know it's
kind of a natural
barrier
um I won't get into this but this is uh
this is the status and MN is actually
the state of the art for similar reasons
uh on not just multi-commodity floor but
many other network design problems uh
some of which appeared in a follow-up
paper by Fleischer and by sorcha and
touchable and several people okay so MN
is kind of where a lot of network design
algorithm problems are are stuck it's
going to be relevant so
okay uh and and I just want to make make
sure so Madhuri doesn't so Madrid
Fleischer they never
touch the iteration complexity right
other goals to improving the cost per
iteration right this was the main
uh advancement
and the starting point of our work which
is kind of the
the main conceptual contribution
is to show that if you replace the
Monroe the shortest path Oracle with a
somewhat stronger Oracle then the
iteration complexity of the Guard condom
in the algorithm reduces dramatically
okay so uh so to describe this Oracle uh
it will operate in this Epoch based
analysis so remember what is the
multiplicative garconium algorithm with
the epochs every Epoch has you just need
to clear all the demands and the natural
way to do this is just decrementally
calling the shortest path Oracle right
[Music]
okay so instead of uh calling the
shortest path Oracle or which needs to
report a path in the range of the EPO
yes and routing one unit of flow on it
we're going to call an oracle which is
called a MSP Oracle we're going to ask
the Oracle to return not a single
shortest path
but a maximally disjoint set of paths
with weights in this range so I was too
lazy to draw figures but basically you
know so we want the Oracle to return to
us
um a maximally disjoint set of paths
which is a packing for this uh for this
so wait so in this in what sense is it
maximal it's maximal in the sense that
if you look at the residual graph any
path which has
length in this range will intersect one
of these blue pads
is it clear what intersect or the edge
intersect yeah Edge intersect okay this
is going to be absolutely crucial in a
second so does the Oracle make sense so
instead of returning a single short path
you want a short path packing so you
want to return all of the maximally
disjointed
okay
all right so in the Min row it's it's a
very abstract clean abstract problem the
Monroe required to return one row with a
small inner product right so now you're
required to return and maximally this
Arc disjoint or support this joint edges
with small inner products it's a
completely abstract linear algebra
primitive right you can think of it this
is one way to generalize it to other
problems so I'm looking for a single
commodity this is just blocking flows
basically okay here your your one one
not even one slide one bullet ahead of
me yeah so in just a sec okay so the the
key uh okay the the first the main
theorem is that if you implement the
epoch based multiplicative weight
algorithm with this Oracle with the
packing Oracle the Monroe packing work
hole then you only need root admiration
and this is tight okay so this is this
is optimal
um
and I just want to say okay so now you
might uh
foreign
Cube reducing it from one of our Epsilon
to the four to one over Epsilon cubed is
already non-trivial reducing it further
to one over Epsilon squared we believe
it's possible but it's it's we have
bigger problems in life so right now so
okay so uh we'll see uh yeah
uh we'll see
remind me of this joke in the end I'll
uh okay so uh okay so before I prove
this as David said
um so you might worry that this Oracle
is super expensive much more expensive
to implement than the Monroe right but
um but here's a prototypical proof of
concept that you you can actually do the
packing problem you can implement the
packing work on the same cost that you
can implement the the single Oracle and
it's exactly a blocking flows basically
the s team in cut so if you need to so
the claim is that okay so how do you
complete compute the the minimum cut in
an st that minimum SD card just invoke a
single call to Max flow right that's
obvious but the claim is that the flow
returned by the max flow algorithm which
we now know how to do in linear time and
near linear time you can collect all the
cuts for the same price
okay so I know I won't go through
through this but basically what you do
is you you call them in the you compute
them in SD flow the max flow sorry Max
flow and then you run a DF you start
running DFS on the residual graph every
time you get stuck on a cut you just
contract those edges and the CL and you
proceed in the claim is that every cut
you hit during this linear scanning
process every cut is a main cut
it's a pretty standard argument right
it's
so the point is the main point is that
the packing problem
sometimes can be
no more expensive than the the shortest
path problem in which case you're
gaining a huge speed up like root M
right okay so the graph is still
directed
yeah in general is there I mean yeah uh
again it's it's this this primitive is
for any packing problem right any
explosive so do whatever you want so as
long as you can again the for the
general the general primitive is a Min
row packing problem instead of just Min
row so you need to return maximally
support this joint
how much time do I have
okay okay so let me just show you a a
Nifty like it's a quick and dirty
version of the the proof the proof for
General capacity is going to be much or
general yeah for General concern is
going to be much more involved so I
won't do it but the proofer unit
capacities is going to be super super
like to line proof Okay so
okay so first of all what the
correctness I claim that correctness is
is almost trivial so if we replace the
Monroe Oracle with Monroe packing or the
shortest path with shortest path packing
the correctness of the garconing Min
algorithm or flasher though is preserves
exact is preserved exactly why
will do what you would do you use in the
decremental algorithm each time you
carve out a short path and you route one
unit of flow here we're doing all of
them in parallel but I claim it's safe
to do that why
does their Edge disjoint right and uh
the algorithm only changes the weight
along the shortest path so if you do all
of them in parallel you don't lose
anything it's exactly it simulates
exactly the same they don't interact
with each other yep
is everyone happy that correctness is
preserved I guess would it also work if
you have like just a tiny bit
uh
uh good question probably I.E we haven't
thought about it but it's it's yeah
maybe this is actually helpful for the
capacity version yeah correctly but okay
as soon as you remember one percent
you're not in that range anymore and
therefore the next one is
one of those
uh not this
um you mean when the packing call
returns and returns this set what I'm
all I'm saying is that if you extract
the packing as a batch right the the the
MSP Oracle returns a maximally disjoint
as Japan if you route and you implement
the multiplicative weight updates in
parallel along all these paths at once
you're simulating exactly what the
shortest path Oracle would have done
sequentially and the reason is that they
don't interact with each other so this
is exactly what guard and Conor would do
um multiplied by this factor and
therefore it's out of the range yeah
after that it's yeah
okay so correctness is is good yeah so
why is the iteration complexity rudime
instead of them okay so it's a very uh
for the unit capacity because it's very
clean proof so let's look at the first
root M iterations of the MSP
based algorithm okay so this is the
first packing so so this is just the
support of the shortest path packing so
what is every red segment it's a it's a
shortest path and the MSP returns a
packing right so it returns these are
just these four four paths yeah so every
segment is a path so maybe the packing
returns in the first Oracle this path in
the second iteration it returns this
packing
yes it's clear every segment is a path
returned in the packing of each maybe
the fifth iteration returns this packing
okay
so there are two cases
if in all first rule time iterations
if the support is large if the packing
is at least through them
then we're very happy why
we congest edges super fast right
because every iteration can just not one
Edge it can just root M edges the
support is very large so we're done
after root am iterations as opposed to
m iterations
why because what will be the total
congestion after root and iteration
every iteration can just root images so
the total congestion will be M or M log
M and therefore one Edge will be
saturated and we're done
okay the other case Okay so so we
terminate in all through them over
Epsilon Square iteration in the other
case there exists
I know and this could happen there's
this one iteration with the packing
returns a very small support so it's
the shortest path is supported on less
than root M edges okay but I claim that
in this case we're very happy as well
why and here's where we crucial use the
maximality what can you say about all
future iterations
they must intersect this packing this
was the definition of the packing Oracle
right
remember what does it mean to return a
packing is that every future
path with uh length in this Edge must
intersect in the in the current type of
mass intersected so every future
iteration is congesting you're
congesting this tiny tiny set of rudime
edges
so one of these edges will get saturated
super fast after in another router
iterations it won't take more than
another Moon emulator is it clear what's
going on here are we looking at packings
uh
so it's across all Commodities at the
same time
or across or like her I I was just
getting oh yeah yeah that's that's the
point it's across alchema you need to
return a set of maximally disjoint
set of paths inside the range between
any pair so in the sense that if you
have any the you know any any route any
feasible yeah demand pair for any
commodity if there exists another pet it
will intersect this Max this MSP this
yep
that's it that's that's the proof of the
unit capacity case it's a little
misleading because for General
capacities it gets much more complicated
even the definition if you think about
maximality is not the same but I have to
finish so uh let me just say Okay so the
general capacities case we pay an extra
log Max Capacity for
due to some exponential bucketing thing
and when you think of it even paying log
and not linear and Max Capacity is
already was surprising for us uh okay
one minute okay
so what's the upshot of the MSP Oracle
the upshot is that it will give you
faster runtime for the entire LP if you
can implement the packing Oracle faster
like ideally in linear time not much
more expensive because you can always
implement it decrementally usually but
that Resorts back to to the madri
approach right
is it clear that one way to to implement
the MSP Oracle is just decremental but
MSP framework offers you a speed up
precisely whenever the packing problem
is cheaper than the decremental problem
yes so when the batch problem is cheaper
than just decrementally doing that okay
for multi-community for unfortunately it
seems that this is not the case for the
like for the basic reason that even the
just finding the closest pair among K
demand pairs
is already requires N squared time or
you know MN time basically for sparse
graphs and this is a reduction by
Virginia from from the shortest path
okay so just the problem finding the
closest pair forget distances forget
reporting forget routing just find the
closest pair is already OV hard okay so
that seems like a real barrier by the
way for improving this
using the multi-comary flow using
Sherman using a multiplicative weights
approach Okay so
however
um
for other network important Network
design problems like cage connectivity
which is also a very well studied
problem which is also stuck on MN time
okay I'll do this very fast here there
is hope to get to actually get uh m to
the 1.5 algorithm we still don't quite
have that okay but it's very close so
the so in this in this problem the
Monroe primitive every row is not a path
it's a Steiner cut okay it's a it's a
cut okay it's a cut separating set of
Terminals and your goal is to report not
a single Steiner cut of small value but
a packing a maximally disjoint set of
cuts so if you remember Grandma's showed
us yesterday or Jason or Grandma that I
remember I I forget you wanted they
wanted to pack Steiner trees right Jason
showed that here we want to pack not
Steiner trees but stunner Cuts okay so
it turns out we can actually do that in
linear time Max flow time and like and
this goes through isolating cuts and
fair flows and all okay so there's a lot
of mess with that
um so we can do that for the St we can
do the packing for s t Min cuts and we
can do it for Global Min cut but for
exact
but what we need for the MSD packing to
solve the problem is we need to report
approximate a packing of approximate
Cuts right because we have remember the
epoch is reports something in a Range
that requires much more work uh and I
think I'll stop here that's that's uh
all I wanted to say I just want to say
that the main problem of course is okay
so find more problems where packing is
cheaper than decremental I think this is
the obvious question another question is
Philip's question can you improve the
current dependency of the MSP iteration
from Cube to square that seems hard I'm
not sure it's worth it but it's it's
definitely a hard question and it seems
doable okay uh and the the last thing I
want to say is that MSB it works for
packing or covering but it doesn't work
for General we cannot get the speed up
for positive General mixed packing
covering okay and I think this is
interesting and all these questions seem
doable like it's not like some huge yeah
sorry for running over time yeah oh
thanks a lot to the organizers and
thank you one quick question anyone well
we cut them all answered already yeah
okay
uh it's not posted yet uh because we
wanted the the the the standard cut
application for that but it will be soon
hopefully
come through the applications on the
previous slide again
uh oh the
okay so this was a specific applicator
it was the
K Edge connectivity problem right so you
want to find a terminal separating uh
subgraph such that every Cuts up every
every Steiner cut
every starter cut has a value at least K
or in other words every pair has a is K
it's a cage connected subgraph okay so
it turns out the Min row problem you
need to solve for this prob LP
is packing not a shortest path but of
Steiner trees of approximate I mean
Steiner Cuts sorry but you can think
about I think cyan and you know and and
Grandma's and Jason mentioned various
other things over the past week right
start using this for your standard trees
matchings of starter you know maximum
matching maximals standard trees maximum
Cuts whatever you want so it's it's
really very general
so the application is more a question to
you
we just focused on one particular one
application we're packing remember
packing needs to be cheaper as cheap
roughly as much cheaper than the
decremental problem
okay thank you very much again
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you